[Music]
so i just moved into my apartment and i
really wanted to do something cool with
the kitchen i love arcade games so i
turned my kitchen from this
to this
so first i started off with the grass
wall it's basically a bunch of 20 by 20
grass squares from amazon that you
connect into lines to fit your wall
you can also add or subtract them in
halves as well to attach them to the
wall all you need is a staple gun and
staples that being said this project is
not for everybody there are other
options that you can hang the grass
balls up with but i personally did not
like them and i didn't think they worked
for my specific wall but feel free to
try them so overall i want to say the
grass while it took me anywhere from an
hour and a half to two hours to put up
luckily i had my big cousin visiting
from new orleans to help me out because
it's definitely a two-person project
alright so next up was the neon sign so
basically all i did was loop a string
that was provided to me through the neon
sign put a nail on the wall and hung it
up all right so now for the fun part the
rk machines arcade one up sent me a few
arcade machines and set them up was
super easy it takes about 30 to 45
minutes per machine but all you need is
a screwdriver and they provide
everything else you need honestly i have
so many memories from playing arcades
when i was younger from my mom always
taking me to the dollar movie theater
and anytime we went we would go an hour
early so we could play a couple arcade
games her favorite game was miss pac-man
so obviously that became my favorite i
love miss pac-man me and her have
competitions all the time we're so
competitive at it and we just love that
game so much
another memory is from my dad taking me
and my brothers bowling all the time we
were a bowling family and one game they
always had at the bowling alley was big
buck hunting and that became my second
favorite game i love to play it and i
don't think anybody can beat me if i
play i'm gonna win that's how i feel
about it okay i'ma just throw it out
there
if you notice every arcade game comes
with a really cool bass we have pac-man
big buck hunter pro x-man vs street
fighter and miss pac-man and each game
has at least four or five other games on
it after that i had to fix the neon
light a little bit just to fit the
aesthetic that i wanted added my two of
ms pac-man 40th anniversary stools so to
fit the vibe that i wanted from my
kitchen i got this really cool bar type
of counter slash kitchen table from
wayfair and i think it just fit the vibe
perfectly i'm here by myself so i don't
need a huge kitchen table
so i'm excited to have this set up i
feel good that now when i invite my
friends over i have a spot that we can
just hang out and not have to go out to
the crowded bars we can just hang at my
house kick it play some games have a
couple drinks
[Music]
if you do try this drop some pictures in
the comments and i would love to see how
you either built your grass wall or
transform your house into one of your
childhood dreams
[Music]
you